there are benefits to living in the
celebrity enclave of montecito
walls to keep out the prying eyes and
the world's most famous interviewer
as a neighbor oprah winfrey once a
wedding guest
now the host of the interview and in
america
that's big news in the united states
oprah winfrey is
is royalty so what can we expect
where she really excels at is getting
emotional and sort of connecting
on an emotional level with some of her
subjects and i think that's where you'll
probably see
some some moments of of uh you know
perhaps
tears i don't think she's there to grill
uh the duke of duchess and i don't think
that was
why they agreed to do this interview
famously of course they did once seem to
want out of the limelight
for those who question how you can be
high profile on one hand and expect the
total privacy of
living somewhere like this on the other
well welcome to hollywood that
is what a-listers here have come to
expect and what they generally get
this family though has something none of
them have
megan and harry are not just another
celebrity couple here the royal thing
over here
is a totally different level has a
totally different cachet
and they have access as royals to anyone
they want here
so will the locals be watching that
interview
no i did watch i watched a lot of the
crown in quarantine
so i do feel like i'm like somewhat
vested in the royal family at this point
but uh
no i don't think it'll be appointment
television for me i'm not one of those
royal chasers i know people who are uh
you know
living and breathing by that kind of
stuff but now they're in the community
and they seem like lovely human beings
i have better things to worry about than
that luke and duchess of sussex
but for millions it will be must-see tv
greg milam sky news montecito in
california